despite the fact that it covers the
majority of our planet's surface we know
remarkably little about the oceans while
we know how to navigate them and how to
send boats from one continent to another
the surface of the water is usually a
calm safe place where all you expect to
encounter are other humans and the
occasional storm what's below the
surface is another story scientists
estimate that we've only explored maybe
five percent of the world's oceans and
what lies in them on top of that they
estimate that we've only encountered and
cataloged 10 percent of marine life that
means that 95 of the ocean is unexplored
and Untouched by humans and that ninety
percent of the ocean species have never
even been seen by humans it makes you
think just what kind of stuff is down
there it could be anything even mundane
ocean life can be deeply strange and
bizarre there are sharks that live for
over 300 years Blind Fish that only hunt
by smell jellyfish that are are reborn
whenever they die if normal ocean life
is this terrifying and explanation
defying what kinds of anomalies could
the oceans we swim and fish in be
playing host to one such anomaly is
scp-835 but before we get started
scp-835 is an old old file it's one of
the earliest in the foundations database
in fact like many of the foundation's
earliest documents it's been heavily
redacted and expunged to the point where
large blocks of the text are missing not
to mention the fact that it's been
locked behind a Content filter but
scp-835 is unique not because it's been
expunged and redacted but because it's
had them lifted versions of the file and
its addendum that are cleared of the
redactions have been Declassified and
released by order of 05-11 to all
viewers for some reason whatever was so
secret about this file no longer applies
but before we take a look at the
Declassified documentation let's look
look at the old version to get an idea
of what exactly we're dealing with here
the attached image for scp-835 is to put
it simply gross it's what appears to be
some kind of bone or muscular growth
underwater a bit like Coral but much
more organic and flesh-like in shape the
growth is mostly white and brown but
large sections are grown over with what
looks like some kind of black mold
spores it's large too almost the size of
a person's chest and seems to continue
out of frame the caption is simply still
image from recording 81. it's not even
clear if this growth whatever it is is
scp-835 or not continuing on to the file
the object class is ketter and the
special containment procedures are
lengthier than most articles and very
detailed they explain that scp-835 must
constantly be monitored and check to see
if it's growing or expanding in the
event that it becomes hostile to
Foundation Personnel something known
only as suppression tactic a-a6 is to be
activated until it ceases any hostile
action the anomaly has to be contained
in the open ocean rather than move to a
water tank or such because of the highly
aggressive response of scp-835 to
confinement for any length of time so
whatever it is it's alive it's expanding
and growing and seems capable of knowing
when it's being placed into containment
and responding angrily it's not only
sentient it's intelligent and aware they
go on to say that scp-835's waste has to
be immediately collected and contained
and that it is to be fed two times every
day though what exactly is going to be
fed to it is redacted in this version of
the file it can also be moved to a new
location up to two times a year but only
if the current location can't support it
anymore and if the move has been
approved by the site directors on top of
that Personnel have to stay away from
scp-835 at least 15 feet they also need
to have safety harnesses attached to
winches on the boat if anyone's so much
as touches as cp835 all the winches will
activate and rapidly yank all the divers
back to the boat from there suppression
tactic a-a6 is again instituted but
there is another line if a staff member
touches scp-835 and is captured by it
then the anomaly is to be monitored
Around the Clock until the subject has
been released very ominous containment
procedures this Predator if it is a
predator has a penchant for consuming
people that needs to be avoided at all
costs but if someone is caught it
releases them after a while the
description of the document clears some
things up
scp-835 is a massive polyps or tissue
growths that resemble Coral it's huge
and heavy though its full weight is
again redacted and the individual
pull-ups are also huge over a meter long
much longer than any known Coral species
the Central Mass is oval and has a huge
three meter long polyp on each side of
it but can't move or budge because of
its huge weight instead it uses huge
tentacles extending from the polyps to
dig into the ground and anchor it in
place against the ocean currents these
are the same tentacles that are used for
feeding and are covered in a sticky
glue-like adhesive they're not just long
and strong either tests have recorded
them damaging stainless steel plating
and speaking of plating
scp-835 is covered in it not steel but
some kind of organic Coral that's much
harder than steel and couldn't be broken
by even Diamond drill bits all the
foundation could get were small samples
and if that wasn't bad enough the
foundation's positive that scp-835 is
growing like the containment procedure
suggested and it's growing fast up to 50
pounds in a single day if it's left
uninterrupted but it can't be stopped it
reacts to certain chemicals that make it
close up like an oyster and stop growing
for 24 hours at a time based on that the
foundation's been able to develop and
use a chemical cocktail to force it to
Halt the aforementioned suppression
tactic a-a6 however the results of
testing it have been redacted in case
the anomaly wasn't disgusting enough it
also vomits that's right every couple of
hours it expels a large mass of some
liquidy sludge material from both sides
so to speak after sample testing the
scientists realized it really is vomit
well part of it the substance is mostly
semi-digested food fecal material and
semen but also contains live samples of
biohazardous viruses bacteria and
parasites some that the foundation
haven't even encountered before as cp835
one of these bacteria
835-i5 is a big problem for containing
scp-835 but exactly why that is is
fortunately expunged from the file as
well between the lethal witch's brew of
dangerous diseases and the diamond hard
shell that covers scp-835's internal
guts it is nearly impossible to
neutralize or even damage it even if you
do crack the shell the diseased fluid
inside would leak out and infect you
full of diseases in seconds wow that's
kind of crazy yeah so scp-835 is a
really really really nasty customer I
mean just by looks alone it's easy to
tell 835 is probably nothing to mess
with but a simple visual of the thing in
your line of sight does no justice in
showing how actually dangerous and
disgusting it really is if you try to
break it you get your immune system
overrun by a cocktail of diseases if it
doesn't manage to eat you first the
document has one addendum an
after-action report by a member of
mobile task force Zeta 9 the notorious
mole rats the mole rats are one of the
foundation's most elite team of Special
Operation troops like all mtfs they have
a very specific specialization one thing
they do better than anyone else in the
world for Zeta 9 it's cramped spaces the
task force is highly trained in
exploring dangerous constricted areas
especially those that lie underground
from Subterranean caves to endless
staircases and basement labyrinths the
mole rats are the best of the best at
getting in and getting out the mobile
task force Zeta 9 had been performing an
investigation on scp-835 albeit when it
was considerably smaller only a meager
four tons and it had informed a second
big polyp yet just like usual four
members of the mole rats were chosen to
begin the investigation equipped with
underwater isolation suits to ward off
any biological threats Lieutenant C
sergeants l and m and Corporal h a
rookie team member who is training with
them and was ordered to only observe
they took a small underwater drone with
them one that would coming very handy at
first scp-835 didn't act hostile or
aggressive towards the members of the
team in fact it even allowed members to
swim up to it and touch it without
reacting they couldn't even tell if it
was alive or not so they sent the Drone
to approach the huge polyp on the North
side while they went around to the small
entrance on the other side of the rock
Corporal H was told to remain there and
make sure that the power cable to the
Drone didn't break off or snap
everything seemed calm suddenly the
drone's claw arm jerked back having
gotten stuck in something and began
thrashing around not wanting to wake the
creature Corporal H moved forward and
tried to free the claw but then he
became trapped too the other members of
the team heard him on the radio
screaming for them to come and help him
and that he'd been grabbed by some
horrible tentacle thing that was
dragging him towards the polyp that had
opened up into a mouth the incident left
lieutenancy a bit ruffled afterward
Jesus Christ I can't do this he was just
a kid it was his first mission I should
have kept my eye on him after a moment
she composes herself and begins to
explain what happened the anomaly
grabbed Corporal age having fooled the
rest of us what we thought was the
entrance to just some cave while the
polyp on the North side was the real
entrance into scp-835 the tentacles came
out of its smaller polyps grabbed
Corporal H and began dragging him in
while he thrashed around and screamed
the boat tried to pull in the winch but
from all the activity the line snapped
in two Corporal H was pulled inside as
cpa35 and eaten the lieutenant explains
that she swam over and hooked herself to
his outstretched hand when the boat
began witching her up she said just as
she assured him that they're going to be
fine and that she's not letting go her
line snapped and they were both suddenly
pulled inside she breaks for a moment
before describing the inside as like a
wet pulsing tube like how intestines
look on colonoscopies they were both
steadily being pulled in by the muscle
contractions what doctors call peristal
analysis the way your body moves food
down your throat and through your
intestines the only reason they weren't
dissolved or crushed was because of the
isolation suits they were wearing but
they still couldn't move Corporal H had
vomited in his suit but they were both
alive the lieutenant Thinking Fast
figured out that if they were moving
through its body they would come out on
the other end in 72 hours they had air
and water in the suits but little
battery and if the heat went out they
would freeze to death she quickly killed
all the lights and Power in both of
their suits to the minimum except the
helmet lights so they could make sure
that the other was still alive the pair
stayed like that for a whole day with
absolutely nothing but the creature's
digestion and their own breathing after
a while the corporal's face was visible
he looked tired and scared she said that
13 hours in the kids started talking and
babbling she calmed him down and they
both slept for a bit but were rudely
awoken by falling into the stomach of
the creature they both fell out into a
small chain chamber filled with liquid
and barely a moment later their suits
began to melt in the stomach acid she
yelled and they both ran for a hole in
the wall
scp-835 sphincter at this point it was
very clear that they made it into the
intestine and it was worse than the
stomach I'm sure you can imagine how
horrifying it must have be to be in the
mix of this creature's fecal waste
disgusted and vomiting the Corporal and
Lieutenant picked each other up knowing
that they were making strides of this
terrible ordeal but they reached a dead
stop the creature's rectal hole was
tightly shut blocking their escape they
decided to wait knowing that it would
have to excrete eventually and after an
undetermined amount of time I mean any
time spent in something's intestines
waiting to be pooped out is too much
time the lieutenant was shot out into
the sea but without the Corporal she is
obviously angry telling the agents to do
something expunged before declaring she
needs a drink and to sleep what a
horrifying story but there are gaps
let's take a look at the uncensored
documentation for scp-835 first let's go
back to the containment procedures what
scp-835 is to be fed is explained any
kind of local fish but higher level
mammals if it goes into a rage State
including humans in fact it seems to
calm down when digesting higher mammals
maybe it's developed a taste for human
flesh in any case the feeding should
never happen without heavy supervision
next the results of Performing tests on
the samples of scp-835 the foundation
was able to get
scp-835 is no normal Coral it seems to
be made from what can only be described
as basic human biological components the
hard outer shell is super dense calcium
like your bones but hundreds of times
harder the polyps are covered with the
same kind of enamel that you'd find on
your teeth and the fleshy muscle that
the tentacles are made of is mostly
mutated tongue cells the creature seems
to have most of the biological system we
have but they've all degraded or mutated
into almost unrecognizability except the
digestive and reproductive systems which
are highly Advanced
835-i5 the bacteria unique to the
anomaly is explained it's how scp-835
reproduces when vertebrates are infected
with it they will undergo a variety of
symptoms gaining huge amounts of weight
despite always being hungry for things
that normally can't be eaten like wood
and raw meat their skin will harden and
form polyps across its surface their
biological systems will slowly stop
working and they'll become aggressive
and then they will drastically reduce an
intelligence and motion except for the
desire to enter the sea sound familiar
that's right being infected by it turns
the victim into another scp-835 instance
with no way to cure it and just like it
seems
scp-835 is still somewhat aware and in
intelligent at one point this thing was
a normal human just in case that's not
horrible enough the after Action Report
has also been thoroughly Declassified
let's take another look to see the real
full story of what happened to
Lieutenant C and Corporal H inside
scp-835 the first reveals when Corporal
H was being pulled into the polyp he was
screaming and crying begging for help oh
God it's eating me I don't
command tells the tenancy to abort the
mission but she refuses to leave one of
her Men Behind holding his hand while
hooking them together then the line
snapped and they were pulled in just as
they were escaping the stomach and right
as she hit the sphincter she realized
the walls of the stomach were lined with
human faces screaming and wailing and
begging to be killed she pulled her
weapon out and began firing into them
and she would have melted if Corporal H
hadn't pushed her through in the
intestine the Corporal began to complain
of a rancid smell she checked and
realized he had a breach in his suit but
quickly patched it but it was too late
she looked at his face and it was
growing pustules already they burst
sprang blood and he begged to be put out
of his misery but when the lieutenant
shot her gun at him all It produced were
empty clicks she had wasted all the ammo
on the crying stomach faces suddenly
tentacles burst through the corporal's
faceplate and simultaneously pinned the
lieutenant down she managed to flip what
had been the corporal over and wrestle
with what was left of him before the
sphincter into the stomach where his
body began to melt in the acid but
before it did she saw the corporal's
face smiling and said he loved her
before he died then she felt a burst of
energy and was shot through the exit
with a troubled gleam in her eyes she
stands there telling her story to the
agent she takes a second to gain some
strength and then says I didn't make it
out intact my suit was breached and I
didn't even realize until I took it off
and saw the rash on my skin realizing
she's going to die she suddenly puts the
room she's in on lockdown and orders the
debriefing agent to evacuate everyone
else aboard immediately just before she
kills the feed she makes one request
that the foundation not try to
decontaminate the small boat just to
abandon ship and Scuttle it on top of
scp-835 on top of the Corporal that way
they can be together in some kind of
sick resting place
scp-835 is the horrible tale of things
that can go wrong at the foundation and
two people doing their best in a brutal
situation but with the modern
containment protocols and ensuring
people know what happened to the pair
the foundation can ensure no one ends up
like the lieutenant and the Corporal
again now go watch scp-3000 anatashisha
and
scp-057-i-t Under the Sea for more SCP
explained videos about mysterious
anomalies that can be found lurking
beneath the waves Surfs Up